the thing in frame is everything working
discovered we divide Lima 2 by M and V
dak Oliveira Carlson this is a custom
sorry where if you play as Felix and
that's me
I place myself at awesome the cameras
off oh thank you for telling me yeah
anystream so well gets uncomfortable you
woke up wake up in an unknown place the
last thing you remember is that you got
kidnapped by untestable statues and the
barrels now you will need to find a way
out of the castle out of this thing
alright hey bro hey there hey Leigh I
love you pretty I always wanted to tell
ya I'm lost all of my skeleton I don't
know how but I am completely flexible
look we can do all kind of sexual
positions now look I call this one the
humping bill all right look you know how
many penises can fit in my mouth 2099
that's why I got this job fixed alright
that's very interesting bro is father
Ellis baby I am sorry I love you all
goddess awesome Lynette no no no no and
then look how big I am my penis is like
5,000 times bigger I mean what am I
talking about it's impossible all right
let's do this I wake up with a swelling
had a slight pain in your neck and a
swollen ti why did I say what happened
you say the last thing I remember is I
got kidnapped by the untrustable status
all right this way today all right mmm
up the staff oh I am so big it's awesome
there was my fallen penis it's super
shrink now actually Jesus cry this way
panting god damn eeeh why are you damn I
want to try sexual positions why you
know let me try sexual positions all
right fine
god damn you let me handle this pity but
Jesus Christ this way oh no oh no no no
oh God
Matt James's grace I wet my pants
holy [ __ ] what was that I cut um I
[ __ ] cut um this way Peter happening
Oh what what what what mr. Sherr aren't
you with me I'm sure but what what
what's going on in it I know you're a
shadow but don't know let's go check
miss [ __ ]
hit it Oh Pat it and now you got a share
but I need to go it is Oh mr. shott are
you doing we should cooperate what is
this place I lost Bailey I waited for
you why did you pass up well I didn't
okay
hi Betty hi Betty oh Jesus Christ a
minute mrs. Yost hell out my soul at
stole I just start calling him as soon a
mrs. stall god damn it ah
oh no no camera activator kidding
these guys are we gonna do this alright
pity I have a battle plan could I take
that I left one and you take the next
one
are you ready insane one two three down
in the kitchen
alright alright I'm dancing I'm dancing
I'm dancing where's the kid
where the [ __ ] is 60 double it it's got
to be a world of the mr. chairs
alright I'm looking at mrs. Harris
where's the stupid it's the [ __ ]
camera activated by you are in Charlotte
help me instead alright
why can't we be friends I need to check
that form check that one like that one
6s Davis guys you had my shoulder right
check that one that one
without an exact form the politics and
Sam are activated Chairman Ahmed shamera
quit dance good why don't you help me
out instead general aggravate Tamarack
me all right there over that is cool
Chad work pheromone Shambo
all right where the [ __ ] is the kid
hey do I have the key nut okay let's get
Nats gotten up mr. Chen I'm sorry I'm
doing the streams to share but you're
only shower mode so it's okay where's
the kid
I don't know storm where's the [ __ ]
key there's so many mr. Sherr I found
that all right now I just gotta follow
this thing all right I did that I did
that yeah that's what I'm talking about
that's key I found the ski all right
let's trade
hey that's one secret room in this map
started first to the right smells nice
Alice today I actually shrink the little
I hope you don't mind my penis size is
not as good
why would I mind if your penis I'd not
nothing nothing forget about what I said
good all right let's continue but
there were nothing in here nothing in
here nothing in here
well what are you doing that iron for me
get out of my room that rubber rubber
rubber aah
Jesus Christ all right all right this
way pity all right fine
should I go upstairs no shake this
room's fast okay what's in it a book say
that you're naughty
all right look at this I know don't
don't like I'm gay mm-hmm mm-hmm
a poem I'm so pumped open it because it
was not to proceed father and you need
to put the phone away this no to us
really huh where's the father
why would you leave me outside I don't
understand all right let's put him here
holy city boy you had a faint sound of a
dot on blacking that's kind of cool kind
of advanced stuff not that door though
is this one happy hello how you doing
did you like I drink I tricked on you
earlier you were so scared ash are you
appear there the son of a barrel he was
screaming for 10 minutes now I wonder
I'm not a son of a barrel but the hell
he always screams in the time of the
night I don't know why I need him
talking about tires now is that my
neighbors or what right uh-huh that's
what I'm talking about yes
that's nothing in there right fine this
is where we came from all right that's
fine that's cool too let's go in here I
guess no that was locked
I'm not the son of a battle Jarrah
our-our-our the thing is can we can we
take the phone oh now you have a slight
melody that the thing that unlocks this
door is beyond a painting oh I already
did it yeah I know you are controlling
this all along well guess what it's your
time to die I'm getting piggy and he
will rape you in the bed Jesus Christ
the jump scares the [ __ ] jump scares
oh I don't trust your rat rod they pick
something up yeah I got a key to the
upper nice fine all right piggy you will
do yay I get to rape someone
yeah I'll rip anything I mean what are
you talking about yay I'm pumped I'm
pumped I'm gonna rape I'm gonna rape
yeah I'm gonna get raped
I mean I'm gonna rape I'm gonna reach
yeah I'm gonna rape yi-yi-yi-yi-yi I'm
wasting my lantern thanks for pulling it
out ah ah it's too fat figure there we
go
all right let's say no period don't let
me yeah I'm pumped
yeah that's what you get barrels all
right let's get the funnel all right
finally Jesus Christ I was one thing I
don't you ain't gonna keep me that this
is not as refreshing well mate holy [ __ ]
all right hey
nothing amiss about it all right nod nod
nod and lighting them let's go here yes
so much lightning them why not under no
no no no dadandan
lightning at my now now now now now now
them now line then out down then up down
there now down and there ain't no
spoofer ways lagging someone tell me
lagging now it's good I'm good
why no no no no no low load all of them
I just want to see I'm on the people
they left no no no no no no no the item
line an at 9:00 and then it bounced and
test you get out of my house battles
alright can go the pro part of the
castle god dammit I don't trust this
[Music]
alright fine I'll just gonna go wow I
bet the bowels are responsible that
science the fauna bros I bet he's here
somewhere